it is not your responsibility to make
your wife happy right
just like it's not my wife's
responsibility to make me happy
it's my responsibility to make me happy
and it's her responsibility to make her
happy and then we're going to come
together and build on that happiness
will smith is continuing to get candid
about his marriage to jada pinkett smith
the 53 year old actor is featured in a
new cover story for gq and discusses the
revelations in his upcoming memoir
titled will the philadelphia native
reveals that jada was not the only one
engaging in other relationships outside
of their marriage he explains quote we
have given each other trust and freedom
with the belief that everybody has to
find their own way and marriage for us
can't be a prison and i don't suggest
our road for anybody i don't suggest
this road for anybody but the
experiences and the freedoms that we've
given one another and the unconditional
support to me is the highest definition
of love anything that i need to make
myself happy
i will present that to my wife that i
need that to be happy divorce is not an
option we going to be together so we
gonna figure out how to be happy the
independence day star also touches on
his fantasies involving other women and
candidly discusses working with an
intimacy coach will's greatest desire in
the world to have a harem of girlfriends
specifically will names misty copeland
and halle berry and says his intimacy
coach even worked on the list with him
will tells the mag quote i don't know
where i saw it or something as a
teenager but the idea of traveling with
20 women that i loved and took care of
and all of that it seemed like a really
great idea and then after we played it
out a little bit i was like that would
be horrific that would be horrific i was
like can you imagine how miserable the
oscar nominee says that the intimacy
coach was cleaning out my mind letting
it know it was okay to be me and be who
i was at the end of the day
it's
just not quitting you know in the gq
article it's noted that will does not go
into much detail about his 23-year
marriage to jada in his memoir will and
i shared some very private truths about
our relationship the hitchstar says that
a lot of details regarding their
relationship have already been made
public including jada's entanglement
with singer august alcina which she
opened up about on her facebook watch
show red table talk in july 2020. i got
into a different kind of entanglement
with august one thing i want to get
clear about and clean up one of the
things that was kind of swirling in the
press about
you giving permission which is
uh
you know the only person that can give
permission in in that particular
circumstances myself yes a relationship
yes it was a relationship absolutely i
was in a lot of pain and i was very
broken now in the process of that
relationship i definitely realized that
you can't find happiness outside of
yourself will explains to the mag in
part quote jada never believed in
conventional marriage and for the large
part of our relationship monogamy was
what we chose not thinking of monogamy
as the only relational perfection i
actually sat down
with will and had a conversation he gave
me his blessing i totally
gave myself to that relationship for
years of my life and i truly am really
really
deeply
loved and have a ton of love
for her as for why will and jada
publicly reacted to august's comments
about his relationship with jada to
protect themselves quote we sort of came
to the agreement that authenticity was
the release from the shackles of fame
and public scrutiny and though will says
he and jada are in a much better place
now he opens up in his book about some
of the toughest moments in their
marriage according to an excerpt from
will's memoir obtained by gq the actor
writes that they reached a breaking
point in 2011 on jada's 40th birthday
something they also opened up about on
red table talk your 40th birthday was my
low point the day after her 37th
birthday i hired a team to orchestrate
her 40th birthday i hired a documentary
team i traced mommy's family roots her
40th birthday was gonna be my thing and
she's told me that the party
was the most ridiculous display of my
ego despite the hurdles the suicide
squad star has opened up about why their
decades-long marriage works many times
including 2015 when he told et this you
can't expect it to be easy it's like
our marriage was the most difficult
grueling and excruciating thing that
we've ever
taken on in our lives and you know we're
just not quitters and by the same token
we're not apathetic so we're not going
to sit there and let it you know be
painful we're going to keep working and
if there is a is a secret i would say is
that
we
we we never went into
uh working on our relationship we only
ever worked on ourselves individually
and then presented ourselves to one
another better than we were previously